et maintenant encore un petit hussards
lunettes noires vive le roi voici jérôme
leroy 25 ans premiers romans à rien du
talent de chardonne un regard bilson
l'écrivain raconte ses parrains à
l'interview vous ou jérôme leroy bonsoir
ya 25 ans et publie aux éditions du
rocher
un roman s'appelle l' orange de malte
son premier roman et c'est aussi ta
première télé alors tu fait une entrée
remarquée sur la sur la scène littéraire
on dit beaucoup de bien de temps libre
et quand on le lit on comprend pourquoi
pourquoi ce titre
le range de mal pascal ni orange ni
malte grand rival jean prat est un
scandale il voulait donner à lucien
leuwen que ça arrive et de la justice
bon bah quand il ya un bon titre chez un
grand écrivain autant le piquet a well
as pas utiliser ouais carrément c'est la
méthode c'est très farceur et autre
chose qui est farceur aussi celle
exergue c'est à dire que je gagne phrase
de la rochefoucauld non je me souviens
pas tu t'en souviens toi oui c'est sur
le fait qu'il n'ait paris depuis les
trois dernières années d'une ou deux
fois il ya une phrase de christophe dont
je me souviens moi je construis des
marionnettes avec la ficelle et du
papier pour vous les montrer
là c'est tout le mélange de basse et de
nommer dans vingt six élèves puis devons
passer culturel aussi c'est à dire quoi
j'ai été d'une génération qui a hésité
entre zulte top 50 et et la littérature
classique et a choisi la littérature
classique un peu quand même
oui pour seulement davantage le sujet
est assez espiègle aussi c'est
l'histoire d'un un personnage s'appelle
kléber qui est pas innocent qui est
paresseux et passéiste on pourrait dire
qui est un coupé peugeot
il sera beaucoup pardonné grâce à ça et
qui est à trouver en fin de saison pour
écrire un essai sur roger harvey qui lui
sert inconnus alors c'est qu'ils seront
gervais c'est le meilleur de tous les
bus à reims est le meilleur de tous les
sahraouis là une halte à l'ennui
ouais il tient l'alcool comme bernard
francou de la poésie de blondin c'est le
meilleur de tous les sahraouis
d'autant plus qu'il est fictif c'est ça
qui est extraordinaire jamais existé
alors au début moi je me disais en dix
ans le bouquin enfin qu'il est vraiment
ici c'est sûr j'ai redressé très bien
foutu parce que il a connu blandin
effectivement il a connu francky il les
a tous connu alors ce kléber vient
d'être quittée par une agnès qui était
sa femme et rencontre cynthia voilà
c'est à dire qu'il a quitté une femme
riche très riche et
ça c'est très ennuyeux pour trouver une
adolescente
oui l'adolescent très très mal et vienne
c'est vrai elle dit d'ailleurs que ses
copines avait fait l'amour
les maîtresses la zone est donc c'était
pour situer le personnage ray oui mais
il est entre deux femmes nées entre
plusieurs lieux il est temps d'essayer
d'écrire un livre c'est un personnage en
mouvement c'est toute la panoplie du
terrain des années 50
oui mais c'était mon livre enfin j'ai
dit quelque part que c'est un catalogue
d'enthousiasmé on voit catalogue c'est
pas péjoratif c'est vraiment j'ai voulu
dire voilà les gens que j'ai aimé on
reproche souvent aux premiers romans
d'être sous influence bien moi je m'en
suis tiré par une pirouette je dis bah
voilà clairement et c'est clair j'ai
clairement voilà les gens à qui je dois
quelque chose lors c'est traîner aux
nouveaux usages
ah oui l'appellation gêne un petit peu
c'est en tout cas un livre qui rend
hommage entre autres russes arb on part
de la rochefoucauld et nouilles m'arrête
a effectivement une lignée et le fictif
harvey ouais
oui mais je revendique tout à fait toute
manière la parenté ya tout pour plaire
dans tout cas je suis client steam enfin
sauvé qui a tout pour plaire
c'est un peu mode quand même n'en trouve
pas c'était le risque ce que j'ai essayé
de faire c'est plutôt justement de les
faire sortir de la mode afin de les
faire rentrer au musée pour autant et de
dire aux gens qui vont venir qui ont été
victimes d'un terrorisme universitaire
où il y avait que du racing grille et de
leur dire voilà ces gens là ont existé
ni et puis je vous le dis à travers un
roman
alors toi bon c'est vrai tu donnes
quelques papiers au quotidien de paris
quand j'entends mais tu es prof de
lettres à valenciennes
oui c'est ou valenciennes mais à part ça
c'est loin fait dans le nord ouais bah
oui commencé au parc à pourcy ne fait
pas toujours ce qu'on peut voir sur la
vie tu fais ce sport étant proche de
l'est alcan est clair que maintenant ils
sont sept épreuves d'europe non non ça
c'est un mythe en europe de l'aide si
les circonstances cgsp
non mais t'as bien fait bon c'est
qu'elle nous a carrément pas le
tourmalet c'est quelque chose qui le
livre je vais pas et que l'on est en
france il écrit le temps dans mon
service militaire de rêve non prof c'est
pas je conseille de force a pour pour ce
qu'il est et affronteront bon moi je dis
je fais mon boulot correctement mais je
reconnais que cette alimentaire et je
fais mon boulot correctement et les
élèves elles sont aussi jolie que
cynthia arrête tu vas te faire avoir des
problèmes si par hasard y avait deux ou
trois qui vont bienvenue à bord il adore
dirais oui on a toujours les mêmes il ya
toujours une rousse au petit matin chrtr
c'est dur de leur maître si serein par
exemple
c'est parce qu'elle peu dur c'est quoi
ce qui est plus dur de résister a dit
non tu comptes vives de tes livres 1
jour ah oui tout à fait mais tu sais ce
qu'il faut faire pour mijoter des jeunes
avec des critiques qui diront du bien de
ton livre des gens qui donneront des
prix enfin tu sais que c'est
épouvantable à faire mais c'est beaucoup
plusieurs figures déliées tu sais ça
c'est pareil nous allons maintenant les
émissions encore naïf
en fait ce qu'on veut dire envie un jour
ou l'autre
ouais pas celui-là est très très bien je
crois que ce qu'on veut dire aux gens
c'est de le lire parce que alors on va
te faire une petite interview vous ou
c'est un rituel
tu t'es prêt
roger dit mais qu'est ce que tu dis si
je te dis rejoint ligneuse c'est un
fribourg par exemple ces derniers temps
a bien montré à quel point c'était
quelqu'un qui comptait pour notre jeune
pour notre génération et c'est capital
c'est de toute manière capital au delà
même du mythe nous est quelque chose qui
pour moi capitale chardonne il a
toujours raison
il a toujours raison pour les femmes
pour les écrivains qui là est né en
politique qui sait peut-être un peu
planté mais pour le reste il a toujours
raison
il avait raison quand il reconnaissait
mort en allant par exemple par exemple
entre morand morancé
c'est un m il fera partie des à mon avis
c'est un jeu j'aime bien il paraît que
c'est risqué mais se demander ce qui
régnait entre elles sont morts j'en suis
sûr il ya quelque chose d'un démodables
c'est dur comme du diamant arrête le
cardinal à cette licence lui aussi c'est
un mythe type qui a tout fait pour
éviter d'être d'être curé un nom et qui
serait enlevé lé qui connaissait les
femmes qui chevauchent et à travers
l'italie c'est l'aventurier tic
l'aventurier et l'écrivain en même temps
que celui qui a ses biens avant
ballereau il incarne le mythe de
l'écrivain aventurier la rochefoucauld à
la rochefoucauld c'est sûrement mon
préféré c'est qu'il a su dire
l'essentiel à chaque fois en quelques
mots c'est quelqu'un qui m'a marqué
profondément c'est rare à notre époque
un écrivain jeune écrivain de 25 ans qui
parle de la rochefoucauld non oui mais
pas réguler beaucoup la rochefoucauld
moi ce que j'aime c'est le oui c'est le
moraliste est celui qui a su dire en
quelques mots l'essentiel fitzgerald
gerald c'est
c'est aussi en plus le mythe de la
mairie qui fait que toute la panoplie
littéraire où tout choix entendement
c'est plus cette dimension américaine
qui est quand même très politique sur
lequel travaille ça a fait dire à gérald
ça aurait pu être une star
marguerite duras pascal ah bon le
bouquin se passe à trouville où
marguerite duras a ses quartiers d'été
d'hiver enfin bon et on la voit un
moment rentrée du monoprix en poussant
son caddie c'est vrai à ses frais c'est
vrai je l'avais fait je déteste pas à la
personne je trouve je trouve un petit
peu anormal qu'un écrivain se prennent
pour une institution et vas y rentrer au
panthéon où il veut quand on veut
rentrer au panthéon de son vivant pour
passer sur de ne pas essayer ouais mais
faut pas s'étonner de prendre la
poussière de son vivant way et bernard
frank alors
c'est une sorte de d'utopie de
l'écrivain pour moi bernard france est
celui qui
qui se dispense presque faire une oeuvre
peut et qui pour sa vie est une oeuvre
certaines mairies ça c'est bien besson
patrick besson ça c'est des gens
beaucoup plus
c'est des gens plus jeunes des gens qui
dans le sens très proche également
quelqu'un comme besson moi je suis
fasciné par sa production et menacent
ils prennent beaucoup écrit beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup et déjà
réédité trois fois oui en fait il serait
dit desjardins et
lettre à yves perdu fait partie de la
dizaine de livres qui ont bouleversé ma
jeunesse
eric 9,9
je me souviens d'avoir lu un triomphe je
devais être en en khâgne dans une 204
blanchard ans sous la pluie en me disant
il va bien falloir que je fasse comme ça
un de ces jours sinon ça ira pas c'est
pas loin le style des wii jeu dans tout
je pense que fin ça va être une façon de
voir les choses mais on off c'est vrai
qu'il sorte de style très très cool mais
c'est pas aussi facile que ça en a l'air
on est des gens qui disent que c'est
facile mais c'est pas facile de faire du
neuf pas du tout nab
tu connais imprenable et oui je connais
un petit peu je pense quoi ouais
j'aimerais bien qu'ils se prennent un
peu moins pour les anglois
ouais
mais sinon c'est sûr qu'il a du talent
lancions une envergure énormes bonus que
tu connais alain bohn en l1 bonne en
tout à fait c'est alors lui c'est
peut-être sur le mans l'héritier le plus
direct de chardonne 1
c'est ce côté très
très retenu très français cette sorte de
magie du style 1
il a instillé 12 c'est le styliste c'est
le styliste pur saisie très
impressionnant lui il est un il est
impressionnant par le style de sa tête
bernard henri lévy s'est pas vraiment ma
tasse de thé un tuyau
karim ont ils m'ont tellement
indirectement donner des leçons de
morale sont tellement permis de porter
des jugements sur ce que
sur ce qu'on était sur ce qu'on
représentait confondante ou d'ailleurs
et puis récupère en auvergne et dans
certaines choses ça me fait bien rire
j'ai eu dans ma grande synthe est
ailleurs bisseuil orbison
c'est bizarre on me les donne line
notamment sarpi mystérieux entournures
album thug un chef-d'oeuvre ça rien à
voir avec la côte normande et pourtant
je te parlais sur la côte normande sans
écouter aujourd'hui c'est bizarre et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de l'ina
l'institut
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus